this is the earth super pretty right
it's also a rare picture because this
isn't a composite it's one complete
image wanna see something even more rare
that's the freaking moon travelling in
front of the earth these images were
taken by a newly operational spacecraft
called the deep-space climate
Observatory or discovered it was able to
capture them because it's way out in a
place of gravitational equilibrium
between the Earth and the Sun called
Lagrange point 1 it's not just out there
to get awesome imagery discover is like
an outer space weather buoy sending home
warnings whenever waves of highly
energetic particles ejected from solar
flares are under an intercept course
with the earth when these particles
arrived they interacted the
magnetosphere and cause among other
things the Aurora data from discover
will give the earth 45 minute heads up
which will give people a lot of extra
time to plan a roar theme dance parties
just kidding the real reason scientists
want that 45 minute warning is because
these solar winds can knock out power
grids to create oil pipelines or expose
plane travelers to harmful radiation and
thanks to the high resolution camera it
also lets us know the moon is still out
there circling the Earth